the good news here hold on is that what
happens going on
republican support is doubling in rural
factory towns where you'd expect
democrats to have leads like union towns
the bad news is republicans don't do
anything anyway so
well here's a story from the daily mail
republican support in factory towns in
rural areas has doubled in comparison to
democrat gains in cities and college
communities in another worrying side for
biden's party before 2022. there's also
good news and bad news so i'll say it
again good news is that people are
finally saying yo the democrats are
ripping us off and it's bad i'll vote
republican the bad news there's what the
republicans going to do mitch mcconnell
oh then the good news and bad news mixed
together depending what your perspective
is this is also talking about democrat
making gains in cities
well people who are here's what i think
is happening you know people uh who you
know grew up in stone mountain georgia
and moved to new york city realized that
it was better way back home and left the
city taking that red vote out of the
city making it bluer and making the
other suburban areas and more rural
areas more red right
like you
well
i don't know how much of a an impact my
single vote is going to have
my area which is but you're just heavily
but there's a lot of people like you
though
and florida is still a swing state every
national election oh for natural for for
a national national election sure but uh
you know and for for uh you know a
senator that's fine
but my local congressperson or you know
city council and all that
my vote's not
likely gonna matter too much unless you
know the the area is inundated with with
disaffected republican new yorkers
you know wait wait i've been to florida
there's a lot of them there's there's a
lot of people there especially in
lauderdale i never leave my apartment so
i can't i couldn't tell you yeah
i'm so i'm so boring i'm so and there's
nothing
it's just like you know malls and stuff
outlets i've been to orlando the city
center yeah has really been uh i don't
know it was just weird being in there it
was like there's like sort of elements
of like new york city in there the bad
parts of new york city but outside of it
it's beautiful and amazing and i
remember staying on this farm in orlando
just on the outskirts of orlando and
meeting some like natural organic
farmers and homesteaders finding a
really great community out there of of
you know liberty-minded individuals that
were very self-reliant which was really
cool and awesome but inside of the city
i was like oh this is a crab hole to be
honest with you were they all in disney
world no we're outside of disney world
uh we did visit one of the theme parks
which is gatorland you went to gatorland
yeah
this is this is what fridays are like
yeah we just run rampant i was gonna i
wanted to bring up you know like is a
red wave gonna happen okay all right
well all right let's i'm i'm sorry i
didn't not mean to derail you tim
talking about disney world
luke skywalker
and uh well hey you're the one that
you're the one that brought up that i
that i moved so um you know that's
that's political you know on you man uh
look you did an amazing segue where you
were like i did move so luke skywalker
by the way
hey at least they didn't start talking
about batman that's true thank you for
not doing that
red wave okay uh republicans
now everybody's upset uh at
at these 10
senators raising the debt limit
what like 400 billion or whatever i
don't know if the house voted yet
i was stuck on a plane without internet
so i'm sorry i'm a little out of the
loop with that uh yeah thanks lydia but
uh yeah
but we
d do you think that
i'll ask luke first uh luke do you think
that mitch mcconnell
uh next year if if the senate
regains uh you know the republicans
regret re regrain times so
i'm anyway do you think mitch mcconnell
will be the majority leader uh i'm not
sure um i i don't think it even matters
and if he is it's just gonna be another
lame duck session i think probably he
was just selected yeah yeah of course
but so but probably it's going to
continue on like it always has and the
republicans are just going to turn over
and not really do much
when that happens who would you who
would you guys like to see
as the senate majority leader rand paul
yes rand paul absolutely pretty much
okay i mean that's that's a pipe dream
that's never happened
i know it's never having a hard question
what's your second who's your second
choice oh josh hawley oh i don't know
ted cruz there you go
i don't care yeah honestly i honestly
it's like uh rand paul's a libertarian
remember how remember how we didn't like
ted cruz
back in 2016. i remember that and now
he's awesome like i don't think he's
presidential i've i've actually said in
in one of my videos that i think that he
would be
like the perfect supreme court justice
oh right but i don't think i don't see
him as ever becoming president of the
united states he's too he's too
polarizing but he's a really he's a
really smart guy and he's definitely won
me over
uh as far as being a senator uh actually
did you guys see this the shane gillis
the the sh you know shane gillis he's
the he's the uh
saturday night live
uh
guy he was he was brought on and then he
was yeah and he was immediately fired
because of things that he said in a
podcast
he well he's he has a stand-up special
that's
that he put on youtube and it's amazing
and it's really funny he's totally like
ripping on ted cruz but in a funny way
and trump and biden and it's definitely
worth the watch but uh but yeah people
just didn't like ted cruz and then he
what however he did i don't know how he
did it but i like i love him not to vote
for him for president is all right uh
i i think the republican party is just
mostly garbage
there's like a handful of people that
are good but i think like holly i i
agree yes he's great cotton is great
yeah
uh you know everybody loves uh
everybody loves rand paul so you know uh
i don't like that zodiac guy um
did you see it he tweeted yeah i mean he
hired someone for his twitter account
and they're doing a great job somebody
i'll be honest they discovered the
identity of the zodiac killer and then
ted cruz we did thank god
i don't know no no he wrote he wrote no
no the there's the there's a new
investigation into who the zodiac killer
is and he wrote no
[Laughter]
i don't like that though
i mean yeah it's aoc style politicking
no i like to i like that ted cruz is
self-aware and and and totally kind of
rolls with it you know like he just
doesn't care i mean he's he's gotten
more insults from once you're interested
through a beard when you're insulted by
donald trump
like everything else kind of like pales
in comparison have you ever have you
ever seen bulworth
yes so that's what happened you know ted
cruz is up on stage and trump's just
rant we're just railing him and railing
him and then he's like hitting his
apartment and he's like just drinking
the scotch from the bottle laughing
ties all this and then he decides to
just wing it and then people end up
liking him but i don't getting back to
the zodiac thing i don't like that i
don't like that
right i don't like that these people
actually came out and said we think it's
this guy this guy's dead he can't defend
himself what's talking about well
because you talked about zodiac killer
no i was talking about a red wave
no we but we ted cruz and you're talking
about come on we're trying to put in the
chat guys come on don't you know back me
i'm reading it they're like yeah they're
like we don't care
there's a delay okay
so you're saying that zodiac killers
could be the senate majority leader yes
sure
yeah i i i or mark hamill
oh luke skywalker sure um yeah but luke
died so he's a force ghost
uh so stupid
no i i there's 14 democrat seats up 20
republican seats up so i'm not sure the
republicans will even take it back even
if but i guess no no they will they will
i'll and i'll tell you who exactly
uh is for first of all it's 50 50 right
now right right and and first of all
this doesn't even make any sense to me
schumer is the majority leader
there's only there's you know how
there's 48 democrats two independent yep
and 50 republicans so technically the
republicans are in the majority at least
in party but uh weird it well what you
know fine yes the the independence they
they caucus with the democrats and
i guess by default right but i uh
rafael warnock he's gone
he he won special election his term is
up in 2022.
this guy is a radical the only reason
uh he he shouldn't have actually um uh
what's his name the other guy uh the guy
that everybody thinks it's cute
uh donald trump
no no uh the the other senator he
basically
um john ossoff yeah yeah okay
see
why
you have to have like 50
right
uh so nobody got 50 and that's why they
had to have the runoff if doug collins
thanks doug collins you jerk if doug
collins didn't run against uh kelly
lefler
she would have won
but instead
you know trump loses the election and
you have all these dis disaffected
republicans going with mail and voting
that doesn't work and and then you have
like
morons like um
uh the woman you know michael flynn's
lawyer and they're like yeah yeah don't
don't go vote don't go through it and
then and that's it
but that's why warnock but warnock he's
he's unpopular
he's
he's going to lose he's going to lose
and it's very possible that mark kelly's
going to lose too
uh oh so so so here we go here we go um
when the republicans take back the house
and the senate we will all be able to
rise up
you know light a cigarette sit back down
and then not do nothing
yeah uh well
i
i don't know if we're gonna get anything
done but i guarantee that we'll
all i only want is the firewall i don't
want the green new deal i don't want
this build back better bs
uh it's it's all
the great reset see see if warnock and
ossoff were not elected
we wouldn't be having this right now
biden would just be an incredibly like
he wouldn't even get anything done
through reconciliation right and it
would be amazing right and he's like oh
i wrote bill back better i wrote all
these things like yeah and we're not
looking at it we don't care like
trying 2022. trying 2024
and he's not running in 2024. he can't
even talk
the guy can't even talk
biden thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time